my name is william cook
and i'm here from the university of
texas at austin
and i'm here to talk about enso which is
a project i've been working on for
oh about 10 years on and off
to be a new
style of programming and so let me try
and
just talk about what uh
well unfortunately
my
thing crashed right before
started and um
seems to have lost some pictures
um
well
that's unfortunate um
well i guess we'll just go on without
them
um what
there should be in there is just a
picture of a person
who is uh getting requirements
which describe what a system does and
doing the normal thing of
looking at the requirements analyzing
the
problem writing code writing lots of
code
and then you can run the code and get
some behavior
so that's sort of the typical
approach to developing software
now one thing that i
think of is that um
what what typically happens is that
there's a separate activity
which is coming up with a strategy
for how you're gonna go about
implementing the system
and um so
strategies don't come from requirements
per se but they're
they're influenced by them and um
the uh
all right are we good nope
the um but it is important that
developers these people who are missing
here
do typically come up with a sort of
strategy for how they're going to go
about
coming up with with the particular
implementation how they're going to go
about writing their code
and when they do the strategy one thing
that happens is that
the strategy becomes kind of a
pervasive element of the programmer's
head
and what it does it it influences all
the code that's being generated
right pervasively
so it's it's you can think of it as an
aspect
the strategy is like an aspect that
covers everything about the code
and influences it
but is nowhere explicit right the
strategy is
itself is not written down anywhere
typically it's just in their head
and what gets written down is the
consequences of the strategy
the decisions that get made from the
strategy
how how are we going to go about doing
stuff looking at the requirements what
we need to do
we generate lots of code so um
this next slide here is um
i'm going to try and reify this
and make something explicit that's
implicit so if you think about it
um we have this requirements what
vague kind of thing strategy is this
vague thing that the programmer gets in
their head
and what i want to do is flip it around
to make those be real things
so um now there's someone over here
where those arrows go person so you
can't see
and another person here with the red
arrow and they're getting the
requirements
but i'm envisioning the
strategies actually being written down
as
actual flexible strategies okay they're
not
not the code that comes from the
strategy but the strategy itself
written down in some generic way
and so the um
the part that is
the requirements that is the details
that are specific to the particular
application that are specific to that
are
written down in a model in this view
now the model itself might contain
a description of structure behavior it
might have code in it as well
so i'm using the model in a very generic
kind of
loose way don't think uml i think you
model
in a a much broader sense
and the idea being that
the model represents sort of the
specifics of the application
the strategy is the specifics of how to
make that application work
and then the strategy implementing the
model the model is given as an input to
a strategy actually
and then that will generate the behavior
and so this is a um
i guess a fairly radical way of looking
at software
if you could do this it would be
interesting um at the same time there
are people who have been saying that we
should do this for a while
so anyway let me let me tell you about
my experience trying to do this
here's an example so
if you want to implement some data
structures one way to do it would be to
create a data model that represented
what you wanted your data to have its
properties
and um that would be the data
requirements
it could go into this data model it
would look like
now you could you could do it a lot of
different ways it could look like a
type system it could look like an entity
relationship diagram
it could look like a
relational model right there's lots of
different ways to represent
data models and the key thing here is
that
one thing that would be interesting is
to allow you to represent
not just the structure of the data but
also its constraints
what if you wanted to to represent the
properties that the model
needs to satisfy so those could also be
represented as conditions
and constraints put into that data model
data manager
is now a strategy for how to implement
that particular kind of data model
now you might have different kinds of
data managers there's relational data
managers
run relational databases there's you
know
uml data managers it can run uml style
data models
there are lots of different kinds of
data models you can just
use c plus plus if you want um
to have an oo kind of data model and
then what you get out of it
is objects that implement some
particular
behavior so that's the idea
to be precise um we have
a paper on this called manage data which
describes a way to do this
one way to do this in haskell i mean in
in
haskell in ruby and um the idea is that
you implement you describe the structure
of the data
using well some data actually
and uh in this case it's point equals
and this is really just a um
a hash record in ruby it says it has an
x field
this type integer and a y field of type
integer that's just a
that's just a data object in ruby
but it happens to look like a data type
it has
all the information you need to create a
data type and so we could actually write
a thing called basic record which is an
example of one of these data model
managers and it would have a new
property or a new method that allows you
to create a new instance
passing it a description in this style
and then it would create a p which is a
point
that has an x and a y and if you say p
dot z you should get an error
so the idea here is that we have
created
cloud what look like classes dynamically
by programming data and using data to
describe data
um
so one thing that requires is that you
override the dot operator
actually actually there is no method
there is no method in here
x p dot x and p dot y those
don't exist as methods necessarily but
in
in a lot of languages you can override
the dot operator
um and you can do it in ruby using
method mything
method missing small talk using does not
understand
high dispatch python lua c-loss
defined method there are lots of
different ways to do this in dynamic
languages
so that's a cool idea
um okay so
the other thing that's interesting about
it is besides
simple behavior
you can have other kinds of behaviors
associated with your managed object what
other things do you want to put in there
well you have mutability
maybe you could have non-mutability
observable observations so that when
something changes
it posts observations automatically
put constraints on it security checks
based on current user
you can have graphs persistence
all these different facets now could be
built into that data manager
and
you can choose what kind of features you
want your data to have
and do that in a kind of a pervasive way
across all your data
as opposed to having to program it up
individually in each uh
in each case because it's a general
strategy
that applies to all accesses and updates
and you can combine them together if you
do this right
you can combine these different features
and have it be essentially a
kind of a menu i want to have a secure
graph based observable data structure
and then you get that
okay so one other thing i want to point
out is that
this this i've been talking about one
data manager here
one one kind of model a data model one
kind of manager
but sometimes there are multiple
different
dsls involved and
what we have is a kind of a chocolate
chip cookie model right now
where there's little bits of dsls get
used
in very specific places in a large
application where the
most of the application is written glued
together with some general purpose code
like java
so this is familiar you could see
that dsls would be sql maybe a
relational data model maybe a grammar
things like that are examples of dsls
what i'm proposing is to
invert this and try and
cover the space with dsls
and then fill in places where you need
some specific behavior
using general purpose code so
imagine having your application so that
the dsls were smart enough that they
actually could talk to each other
as opposed to having to talk to some
glue code
and uh if you could do that then you'd
get something more like a blueberry pie
with
four or five dsls embedded with
specific gpl code and this is a little
bit more like what you might see
in javascript inside of gpl you know
general purpose code inside of
html
okay so i mentioned other kinds of dsls
grammars are another one besides data
models we have grammars grammars are
very interesting
they're mapping between text and an
object graph
one way to look at them um
we have a notion of uh object grammars
and um
they
are allowed to create graphs not just
trees
so it's interesting how to do that
here's an example of a point which would
be written
open for in x comma y close paren where
x and y are
integers um so
the grammar notation for doing that in
our system
has some uh has some more stuff in it
uh in addition to
here's the grammar rule here can you see
that no
i guess you can't
yeah so here's the grammar rule um it
says that it's going to create a point
and it matches
left open paren it's going to set
x the x field of this point to
an integer and it's going to match a
comma set the y field of the point
to an integer and then match
a closed parent so it's actually doing
more work than uh
a normal grammar would do because it has
these fields
for example and the point constructor is
is explicit here
so we're we're integrating the creation
of the object
with the uh syntax of the of the grammar
and actually this allows it to be
bidirectional as well
so that you could say to print a point
that says to print a point print out the
x field as an integer
a comma then the y field as an integer
and then a colon
or a close paren or
you can read something in that way
and create a point so it's it's nice
that way
um we have
an integer literal
has a fixed built-in type
but you could certainly extend it with
other specific types
so it's bidirectional you can parse and
pretty print
and it's a gll parsing and it's
interpreted so one thing that's
interesting about is we don't do
parser generator as well we don't do
code generation in general we just
interpret the models directly
so it interprets the grammar
on the fly um
so here's a couple of
larger examples with um
all the pieces involved so this is an
expression grammar
it's got a grammar here that says it's
got
a left and a right
um as ms well e
i guess this is uh
it's a left recursive rule
so it can have any number of e's to the
left
and then a right m or just a plain m
and then m is a multiply rule
which is a left m and a write p and a p
is a integer or
a parenthesized expression so that's a
grammar
that will parse or print out
an expression and
there's a schema
that i didn't talk about very much but
it's a it's a dsl for describing
data structures schema language and it
happens to be
class-based has a class
expression class num less add
classimo left and right expressions
these should all be
expressions
i'll fix that let's see if i can do it
um
we've got some serious uh
great
um
so these are expressions and then
there's an interpreter that interprets
them
in the middle here
and it says how to evaluate a value how
to evaluate an add how to evaluate a
mole
and then we can obviously type in an
expression and get it to evaluate
serious water coming in all right
um here's a state machine grammar
start state list of states state has a
name and a set of transitions
transition has an on an event
go to a new state so here's an actual
state machine
here's the schema for state machine this
is actually a state machine over here
this is the way it's written
start stage is opened on close go to
closed
on close it can go back to open or
locked locked goes
back to closed when you unlock it and
then
there's a simple interpreter here
that can interpret the state machine so
we read in a state machine into the
schema
it has a name
output transitions input transitions so
it's a it's a fairly nice
data model for for transitions and state
machines and then we can run one
basically while we get ass
prince the current name of the state
input
is uh the current line looks for an
output
an input that has that transition if it
finds it sets the current to that
transition too
so it's a fairly simple approach
i don't want to go through this too much
but i do want to mention that this is
our grammar
of grammars so grammars
are describable
as grammars obviously
and uh
they have rules they have alternatives
they have sequences field names
references call code
um and uh
so just so we know that we can do that
and then this is um this is an
interesting picture
it shows the relationship between these
four
key schemas at the very top of our
system
so there's a schema schema which
describes the structure
of data okay so this is the schema
schema
it describes how to describe data and
since
it's data it describes itself
down here there's a grammar grammar that
describes how to describe grammars
and the grammar grammar um
now we have we have a grammar schema
that's the schema of how to represent
grammars
okay and that's an instance of schema
schema
and it has as one of instant instances
the grammar
grammar and then we also have
a schema grammar which is
a grammar for how to describe schemas
and so it is formatted by
well the schema scheme is formatted by
the schema grammar
and schema grammar is formatted by the
grammar grammar
and the schema grammar is formatted by
schema grammar so
these kind of fundamental
four schemas
are kind of the root of the system
and they get things going
and um in particular the schema schema
has to be an instance of itself
and the grammar grammar has to be
formatted by itself so they
actually tie themselves off as a loop
okay so
now i'm going to talk a little bit about
diagrams which are
a way to present information
so a diagram is a is a model
it's like a think of it like a draw
draw a document it's got shapes
it's got things in it and
allows you to move things around
basically so here's an example of a
diagram
happens to be a representation of a
schema schema
it says the schema has a list of types
which are
have a name and a type has two different
subtypes primitives and classes
classes have a list of super types and
defined fields and a field has a name
whether it's optional
whether it's many valued whether it's a
key whether it's auto whether it's
traversal
and an inverse field and a type
which sends it up to its type so
that's just a diagram the interesting
thing is that
we can then um
define a stencil which is a mapping
between some high-level model
and a diagram this is going to be a
presentation
of well
the information in this diagram
onto this diagram itself so what that
would look like
is
something like this it's a model that's
a mapping from an object graph
onto a diagram and it
um
in order to implement it it's going to
inherit the functionality of the diagram
editor
it's going to map object graphs to
diagrams
and maps the changes back to the object
graph so the idea here is that
this is actually bidirectional now if
you make a mapping between
a um
this is a well it's hard to show what a
stencil looks like i'll show
a couple pictures of it in a minute but
this is a running application now that's
a stencil that's taken
the schema schema and mapped it onto
diagram
okay so we have a mapping from schema
schema's two diagrams
now if you change the diagram like if
you add delete a field
it can change the corresponding
item in the actual schema schema or add
a field
so things like adding and removing menus
you don't need to specify that those
really need to
um well
there needs to be one bit that says
should this
menu be created or not because for
example down here
there's a field named field
and it has a list of its fields in it
unfortunately it's kind of self-self
referential
but clicking on one of those fields and
saying delete could correspond to
deleting the corresponding object in the
actual schema schema
or adding a new field you could add it
so all you really need to know is
whether or not the menu should be there
and in general they should be
and so it's more than just
the the binding is is more than just
based on the data like the
names it's actually based on the
structure
as well it's quite interesting
here's an actual picture of a schema
[Music]
it says that to diagram a schema
make a graph
and then make a menu class for each
class
in schema classes
label the class make a box
so this is basically making a box with
the width of the color putting vertical
text in it
here it puts the class name and then for
each field
if the field type is primitive i'll put
a horizontal row which has the field
name a colon
and the field type name
so it's fairly concise
description of how to create
this box here from a class
now it omits that these these fields
that are out here
the deleted fields
and the type and the inverse those are
not primitive values
so those get left out from the list of
only the primitive only things with
primitive values booleans and stirs
get included in the
so um
the other thing i want to point out is
that
one of the big problems going back to
that original
idea of how we do software now where we
have requirements and we
come up with our strategy and we write a
lot of code
problem is that if a year after doing
that
you look at your thing and you sit there
and you go oh my god
there were elements of my strategy that
were wrong i should have done it
differently
you pretty much hosed because
you have very different code to write
everywhere because the strategy is
different
and you basically just give up you don't
bother
so changes strategies are very difficult
after
a system has been built whereas
with this system that i'm envisioning
the strategies are actually
implemented as
a kind of meta program and
if you change them then the system will
behave differently
so
here's a little bit more of the
stencils this shows that how the
connectors are created
for each class in the schema classes it
goes through
again and makes a menu
parent for the
super class and it makes a connector
between
the class and the super so this is
basically connecting
the class to its super class if it has a
parent
and also for relationships i need that
as well
okay so
the last thing i need to point out is
that
it's not just one data model it's
multiple data models
so when requirements get read in there's
actually data security user interface
workflow etc
multiple different facets of the system
need to be described
and then there needs to be multiple
strategies to coordinate to deal with
all those different facets
of the application to create the
behavior so
it's really a multi-faceted
multi-strategy
setup and in particular some of these
strategies
can also be like aspects
in the sense that they
apply to other strategies they actually
actually are strategies that apply that
modify other strategies
so for example debugging is a strategy
that
can apply to a general interpreter you
you wrap the debugger around the
interpreter it it will
be able to hook into the right places
when the
debugging should occur and also
potentially
show the right information
based on the data that's in the strategy
so it's quite interesting
all right so just want to point out
um there's an interesting language
workbench challenge that we
got involved with um where they had a
model they had a challenge to try and
create
languages for um they have a different
challenge every year
and one year they had a description of
how to
create a heating system so we
implemented some models for a physical
heating system and a controller for a
heating system
and a simulator to run the heating
system at a state machine to run the the
controller
what it looks like is this so here is a
an example heating system implemented in
our system
oops sorry
and it's got a boiler and a return and a
burner and a pump
and a valve and a radiator
gas and
you can see how hot things are
and then there was a controller which
was a
state machine and it was in radiator
mode right now
but it was you know able to go to
cooldown mode running mode boiler mode
ramp up start and
so it had conditions on it to determine
when to start running and when to move
and then there were strategies for
running these things
how to run these models and yeah
so that was quite interesting and um
so it all was asynchronous too that the
simulation was
updating the models and the model was
changing
at real time and you could also interact
with it and change the
state and change the desired temperature
in
the room for example and it would all
work nicely
okay so enso is currently slow but
usable
it's um
we're looking at using partial
evaluation to improve its performance
haven't really done that yet in full but
we've done some experiments
and um my job is to give compiler people
something to do
which is make something really slow and
then give it to people who can make it
really faster
um okay so i'm running out of time so i
think i'm going to skip this
just threw it in here in case i needed
an extra
little discussion of trees versus
graphs and so it's based on graphs
versus trees
in general which makes things a little
more complicated so in summary
and so is about executable specification
languages
that's what modeling languages are
things like data grammar gui web
security
queries etc get enough of those
connect them together so that you don't
really need
glue code they're implemented as
external dsls they're not embedded
they're interpreted not compiled
and um composition
of the interpreters is with language
they're objects so
they just compose very nicely and also
it's self-implemented so
and so it's implemented in itself
which is using ruby and javascript right
now
partial evaluation is on the way for
speed but we haven't done that yet
and so that's it
going to end with our kind of
takeaway picture which is to don't
design your programs
anymore instead program your designs
the idea try and make your designs be
programmed
and that's it so thank you